1900 milliards d'euros c'est la somme
que bruxelles a reconnu comme étant des
aides légitimes des états membres pour
soutenir leurs entreprises et berlin a
frappé fort
parmi les aides validé cinquante deux
pour cent concernent aujourd'hui
l'allemagne ce qui fait grincer des
dents les aides sont donnés par ceux qui
peuvent le faire
si l'un peut en donner plus qu'un autre
nous sommes en train de fausser des
conditions de concurrence le marché
unique sera fortement affectée par la
manière dont les aides d'état seront
accordés derrière l'allemagne la france
se situe à guy 7 % l'italie à 16%
d'habitude prudent en matière
d'investissement le gouvernement
d'angela merkel n'a pas hésité cette
fois ci a déployé des moyens dignes de
la quatrième puissance économique
mondiale un plan de sauvetage historique
de 1100 milliards d'euros a ainsi été
adopté pour défendre la première
économie européenne face aux coronavirus
dans l'hexagone le chiffre est 10 fois
inférieur berlin au plus près de ses
fleurons industriels
dernier exemple la compagnie aérienne
lufthansa est en discussion avec l'état
allemand en vue d'une nationalisation
partielle et du led 9 milliards d'euros
pour éviter la faillite
des investissements colossaux qui font
jaser
chaque entreprise que ce soit en
allemagne en france ou en espagne doit
comprendre que tout s'arrête lorsqu'un
pays s'arrête l'industrie automobile
n'est pas seulement situé à wolfsburg ou
stuttgart
les fournisseurs sont répartis dans
toute l'europe vous ne pouvez donc pas
sauver votre propre économie simplement
en sauvant votre propre pays nous devons
sauver l'europe dans son ensemble
berlin qui ferait cavalier seul selon
certains à bruxelles tandis que d'autres
semblent réticents à critiquer
l'allemagne c'est important que
l'allemagne agisse de la sorte car elle
va d'une certaine manière faire office
de locomotive pour l'europe
ce qui est triste c'est que tout le
monde n'a pas la même marge de manoeuvre
budgétaire que l'allemagne
il va falloir trouver des solutions cela
risque donc de ne pas suffire pour
apaiser les tensions autour de
l'allemagne ces dernières semaines
main n'a pas manqué une occasion
d'afficher son indépendance vis-à-vis de
l'otan comme de bruxelles